this is what you had to do to us tonight
okay fancy this is what she had to do to
us tonight will oh no listen
yeah no i feel like
in this suit we should call you willard
well yeah really yeah
mr willard mr willer
sir sir
that was an accident too that was an
accident that was an accident yeah this
is a little a dress i had in the closet
this is gareth pugh it's vintage and
when i saw it i just knew i had to own
it so i i was like okay this is perfect
now i didn't know that he was wearing
yeah yeah no this worked out
no it just so happened
yeah that was just because it's here
yeah yeah
we're looking like them old people
that got a camper so will you already
won the golden globe for this you're
nominated also for critics choice
nominated for an oscar all the good
things for this role and you said to me
i don't know if you heard this jade but
he said to me that
internal he never really spoken he
thought after the pursuit of happiness
he wouldn't do anything
better than that and then you saw this
and i saw king richard you know it's um
you know there's an extra level of
of
fear involved with doing something about
someone's life because you know that
they're going to see it one day
and they're going to tell the world that
either you hit the mark or you suck and
ruin their story you know so
um with this one
the entire williams family signed off
loved it venus and serena said they
cried all the way through and you know
for me as an artist that that is
you know total nirvana first time you
saw it what was your thing oh i was just
so proud i mean we had so many
conversations about it and he was very
nervous you know what i mean um but just
for him to have the opportunity to
highlight such a
beautiful black family that really
struggled
um and through their struggles
made something very beautiful you know
what i mean so we found it really
inspiring and i'm just super proud of
him i'm super super proud of her have
you thought about the fact that it's
going to be the 20th anniversary in the
oscars when you and denzel back up
against each other i know
yeah no that's really that's right yeah
that's a great name
hopefully we'll need a tiebreaker after
i like that i like that and by the way
you know the folks are mad at you for
bringing michael ely into bel-air
they are doing a brilliant job with bel
air too that cast is ridiculous
um you know we've we've seen the
episodes ahead so we know what's
happening but it's uh it's they that was
a that was a heavy lift yeah you know
and uh they're pulling it off
you